there are new details this morning
surrounding the FBI rate of one of paw
Amana forts Holmes agents raided
president Trump's former campaign
Chairman's home two weeks ago they were
reportedly looking for evidence related
to the special counsels investigation
into Russian meddling in the 2016
presidential election mana force
spokesman said he has consistently
cooperated with law enforcement and
other serious inquiries and did so on
this occasion as well Julianna Goldman
is outside FBI headquarters in
Washington DC Julianna good morning good
morning well it's a very aggressive move
and another indication that Muller's
investigation is heating up as you
mentioned man affords team says that
he's been cooperating but this rate of
his home indicates otherwise
formal prosecutors tell us that
typically in white-collar crime
investigations lawyers negotiate a
handing over of evidence but the fact
that they executed a search warrant
means that they felt they needed the
element of surprise they didn't trust
man afford not to destroy materials that
could be relevant to the investigation
now something else to consider sources
have told us that the Special Counsel is
investigating man affords business
dealings and again typically in Criminal
Investigations prosecutors will they'll
try to flip witnesses up the chain of
command and that's that could be what
Muller is trying to do here to squeeze
man afford to pressure him to give up
information on others in the campaign
Charlie the specials off the special
counsel's office declined to comment
Julianna Thanks